you're gonna miss us no no on the way we
got a rock hit the windshield of my car
some flights are getting delayed some
flights are getting canceled happy we
can't believe nation we are off to
Philadelphia and then I'm going to Palm
Springs and I'm gonna take you on a
journey with us
[Music]
so Nina and I are off to Philadelphia
PTIN is gonna stay with the grandparents
so Steve oh mighty no we're gonna miss
you we are going to Philadelphia for an
event with Satguru we did a thing with
him in Toronto and now we're going to go
su to his inner engineering workshop in
in Philadelphia and then Nina's gonna
come home Monday morning to go to work
and I'm gonna head to Palm Springs for
an annual event I go to with YouTube
creators called clemmer con and I'm
gonna take you a long journey for the
entire ride with me and Hayden get to
stay home very exciting very very
exciting
first stop first stop chop up Hayden and
the dog and then head to the airport
[Music]
it's windy it's windy
so on the way we got a rock hit the
windshield of my car look at this that
is gonna be an expensive fix expensive
fix but it's okay it's gonna be a good
trip it's gonna be a good trip Timo you
get some doggie friends for the week you
get doggie friends you're gonna miss us
no well well I'm gonna miss you anyway
[Laughter]
all right that's it Nina drop the boys
off Philadelphia here we come
[Music]
are we gonna get delayed Nina no no
we're not gonna get delayed we're gonna
we're gonna get out on time in a safe
manner
[Music]
so we decided to park our car Nina's
gonna be coming back Monday morning what
time you're leaving to like 6:00 in the
morning on Monday she's gonna leave
she's gonna leave Philadelphia at 6:00
something in the morning that means have
to be there at like 4:00 in the morning
so she can get here for 7:00 in the
morning and then go right to work see
the nine-to-five job lifestyle good job
Nina way to hustle
so she's gonna come back to pick up the
car while I pop the plane to Palm
Springs and just suffer in the heat and
just be so upset and missing the wife so
much you know right I'm loving the wife
okay we love you we love Lena so much
[Music]
where's your belief shirt mean I usually
you have your belief hoodie on oh that's
a t-shirt but where's the hoodie not
representing I'm representing this time
on the inside well it's not actually
quite the inside it's like the middle
layer we just did an announcement saying
that due to the windy weather they are
delaying some of the flights it's not so
funny because on our New Year's chip we
were still go to Dallas and it got
delayed three or four or five times and
then we sat on the airplane after being
delayed multiple times a couple hours
and then they refused to let us take off
so we had to go home so fingers crossed
we got out not just on time but period
today so we were just told that it is
100% going to be late leaving
but but they haven't talked about
cancellations yet what if what do we
think Nina we're going to get out can
you give us a second
yeah
[Music]
why are you laughing Nina did a goofy
picture at all okay let's see if we get
the ex who's gonna get the ax moment of
truth
I'm gonna truth Nina don't get us a
nexus time okay go go go go say yes pay
attention here yes there we go yeah no I
mean is good let's see that picture yes
sorry that's not the greatest I have a
double chin okay and hit different
things
what's why is it I can't we are good
look at that that is a happy picture
welcome to the United States it's
official
we made it well well you're gonna be
like the Statue of Liberty
good job mean it oh we didn't make it
we're still we self he got on the plane
but we're in we're international
territory now moment of truth time to
see how much of a delay there is an hour
flight what do you think you Nina I'm
thinking like seven and a half minutes
seven and a half minute delay let's go
let's see yeah on time huh what do you
think is it legit is it legit are we
buying it we're buying it we're totally
buying it Nina totally buying it
so what's become our airport tradition
is getting that who's to juice who's to
juice it's some kind of nutrition
bananas away for me what are you gonna
get any net usual all right I know that
is tropical
oh that's good been a long time you
gotta let my booster juice
[Music]
some flights are getting delayed some
flights are getting cancelled we're
getting delayed already how many how
many minutes it's been tell me since to
leave we're systole by now but we
haven't been canceled yet what do you
think Nina what do you think I think
we're gonna make it I think we're gonna
make it I think we're gonna make it
the airport is certainly giving
as you can see the businesses are all
closing down can't get food anymore the
hallways are all look there's nobody
here we have maybe the last flight out I
hope I hope oh this can't happen again
we've got to make it come on
airplane guides make it happen
Philadelphia or bust
name is getting a little tired little
frustrated but we're gonna make it I
think we're gonna make it
we are getting and we're supposed to
leave at 9:20
it is 10:45 I think were the last people
in the airport but we're getting on that
didn't save us last time last time we
got on we had to get off all right in
Dallas but I have a good feeling it's
gonna work leaving 11 o'clock
let's go Nina let's go Nina we're gonna
make it to Philadelphia yeah good thing
we don't have an early morning tomorrow
[Music]
looks like you're going
[Music]
[Music]
because
[Applause]
there was a bird strike
the mess
it's 1:00 a.m. made it off the flight
[Music]
Nina is just a ball of energy right now
but the past that doesn't matter that we
made it we made it we made it we made it
time to uh Papa eeper head to our place
and crash hard before waking up tomorrow
and have a little bit of time in the
morning maybe explore touch and then
head out to the sadguru event yeah
[Music]
you
[Music]
it's late past two o'clock in the
morning we found their place we're gonna
go up figure out how to get inside and
get some much-needed rest
we both quasi passed out on the ride
over
but anyway get some sleep rest up tackle
Philadelphia tomorrow morning a good
night